[Music]
okay so in this class we're just going
to continue with porn end games what we
were discussing in our last class and
the examples that we're going to to
analyze are a little bit more difficult
this is the first one I'm going to ask
you a simple question
who's winning if it's right to move and
who's winning if it's black to move
think it thoroughly
Arjun I know you know I'm aware of that
I might ask your opinion on the last
example because that one is a little bit
more difficult than all the others
sure you start yes
so if it's white to move white is
winning if it's black to move black is
winning there's no such thing as better
in this endgame
it is either winning or it's a draw yeah
it's very easy to calculate it's very
concrete so please exemplify yeah tell
me the moves tell me the moves if it's
white to move well that's what I meant
that's what I meant by taking your time
before giving me the answer because it's
all about calculation I'll give you a 30
more seconds maybe one minute try to
phrase your answer in the meantime you
have a question yes
yes white is going this way black is
going this way it's also written on the
side of the board why it's a good
question
okay thirty more seconds
all right you start
very wrong answer whoever moves it's a
draw no matter what no that's definitely
not the case he was right he was right
whoever moves wins because they're able
to create something that we call
attitudes one have you guys heard of it
Susan
what does it mean basically it means
that we're putting our opponent in a
very uncomfortable position in which he
is forced to move but he doesn't want to
move if he could pass the turn he could
say passed then he would be fine if he's
forced to move then he's losing then
he's allowing you to do something and
grab the advantage so now let's start
concrete moves if white is to move what
should we do
Tigra
that's the losing move that's the losing
move let's understand why because now
I'm going to go king before and we
entered the dudes one position that I
was talking about because white is
forced to move but he doesn't have work
to move and still protect the pawn right
he has to leave this pawn unprotected
and then black is just going to capture
the pawn move away and then move his
pawn to promotion so for example if he
goes I'm like king h4 I'm going to take
and so on yeah and then I'm just going
to push my pawn all the way down the
board and promote so if you lose the
pawn you're probably going to lose the
game let's try to avoid that all the way
in the back okay King to h4 no because
right now I'm going to play this move
King to e3 I'm going to attack your pawn
and no matter where you're defending it
from you can defend it from two places
g3 and g5 right if you play King g3 I go
king before then King g2 then I take on
f4 and this is a draw yeah but you can
make a draw the most that's not good
because white is actually winning in
this position you tell me blue King g6
exactly we're attacking the pawn now
we're forcing black to defend it yeah
he's going to go oops he's going to go
King to e4 and then we're going to be
able to do what yeah King g5 and we
reach that dudes one position
yeah with black to move black is forced
to allow white to capture the pawn on f5
and then this is just going to be an
easy conversion yeah
easy win so be very very careful one
move and you might lose a winning
position yeah always be extremely
careful okay
next one this one was fairly easy how
about this one you're white
what is the assessment of the position
and I want a concrete variation I want
you guys to propose a concrete variation
Arjun I know you no stop raising your
hand
why to move why to move yeah if it would
be black to move he would do what he
would move his king you move hissing
here
he would attack this pawn and you cannot
really save the game but if it's white
to move maybe you have better options be
very careful
are you a hundred percent sure of your
answer okay go ahead he's going to get
worse so it's a draw so or it's a win
white is losing no white is act white is
actually able to make a draw in this
position now try to find the solution
because it's not easy yes I cannot move
on b5 but do you want to go away from
the pawns as white that doesn't make a
lot of sense you want to stay as close
to the pawns as possible if you go away
then that's exactly what I'm going to do
I'm going to a king before I'm going to
take the pawn and then I'm going to
promote it yeah that's not the technique
to save the game to try to save the game
at least you have to go you have to come
as close as possible to the pawns and
try to stop blacks promotion that's the
only way to to do it but you also have
to be a little bit tricky before that
yes orange
King to e5 okay an interesting idea the
problem is that I'm going to continue
with my idea I'm going play King before
attacking your pawn king the six then I
take but now you're a bit too late don't
you think so
the point is not going that way
what are you thinking the pony is going
that way yeah the point is going this
way and once again you're very very far
you cannot allow yourself to fall as far
behind you don't get another chance for
the moment yes King e5 you mean okay
the same the same thing that's that's
what he said as well
mmm King d5 the same I'm going to take
[Applause]
it's not as easy right it's not working
kingi five is now working he's right
because I'm just simply going to be able
to take your pond and then push it all
the way down and promote it and win it
so give it some thought I told you it's
not going to be that easy if it would be
I wouldn't ask you it wouldn't be the
advanced class
all right hmm a5 of course what you're
going to do is sacrifice the pawn is the
only way to actually make a drawing in
this position because you're going to
create a marginal point one on the rooks
file a or H and with those ones is very
difficult to win well sometimes I mean
it's either a win or it's impossible to
win yeah it's either a draw or a win so
now you take on a5 and the thing is
you're going to reach this square in
time if it would be black to move it
would be winning because black would go
King c4 and shoulder the king he the
king is not going to be able to reach
this b1 square but like this with white
to move I'm going to go King D 3 King
before King C to a4 King b1 and as long
as I reach this actually all the way to
here this three squares this is just
going to be a draw yeah easy draw I'm
just simply going to play King a1 King
b1
let's go like this and you cannot take
me out of there out of the corner yeah
so what was the key guys to do what
to do what create a marginal pond yeah
for your opponent it's much more
difficult to win when you have a
marginal point yeah because you don't
have an extra line to maneuver with your
King around yeah with this King I can
maneuver around my pond if my pond would
be on the marginal file then I cannot
maneuver around it yeah okay next one
so as you can see it's getting difficult
more difficult and more difficult this
one is actually quite tough white to
move in most of the one of the puzzles
we're going to see is going to be white
to move I don't know I'm not going to
give you I'm not going to give you that
clue at least not not as of yet but to
be honest a draw is quite easy to make
right yes what was your question
hmm yeah if you want to make a draw you
can just go up for a 5 we exchanged the
pawns and that's going to be a dry up
quite easy think before you answer once
again
because for this one the answer I would
say is a bit counterintuitive I doubt
you know it you just saw an idea and now
you're raising your hand you saw you
solve this before on chess skin and you
remember the answer just this morning
wow you got really lucky there okay
let's see if you solve this right I'm
very curious to see if you solve this
right come on tell me the answer tell me
the answer King if I'm wrong don't blame
the website don't blame the website now
I mean that's what I'm saying
even if you think you know it even if
you think you've seen it try to
understand it first and recheck your
answer yeah I'm going to show you why is
why it's not correct
I'm going to go King C for now you're
going to attack my pawn most probably
now I'm going to go King D for now if
you take my pawn I'm going to do what
King EE for and now after King g5 King
f3 the pawn cannot move I'm grabbing the
pawn and it's going to be a draw so
that's what I'm saying don't hurry
I have to tell you this position even
Grand Master's have problems solving
I'll I'll let you answer Arjuna in the
next five minutes if nobody else finds
it blue over there
well you can check your guesses again
King F for King C for by calculating
King j5 King D for I'm letting you take
my pawn the problem is I'm reaching this
square this important square and if I
reach it
then it's going to be a drop YUM yes
absolutely you can but then I do what
I'm just going to attack your pawn
either from e3 either for me for it
doesn't matter as long as I managed to
create contact with your porn I'm safe
black is safe so i'm going to go King
III you take then I take on f4 and we
shake hands for a draw yeah so you have
to be very very careful again I said
it's counterintuitive so what that means
is that you're probably not thinking
about that move in the first place
f4 is a good good try
it's not it's not good though I'm going
to go king c4 who has the opposition now
black yeah so now you're gonna go king
e5 most probably to try to get the pawn
and then I'm going to do what king D 3
of course King f6 and I'm just in time
to do what to attack your pawn to create
contact with your point King to e4 King
to e3 doesn't really matter and then
it's just going to be a drop
so to be honest you guys were raising
hands in the first 10 seconds and we
almost checked every possible solution
none of it was right so now obviously
you don't have plenty of choices left
try to at least give me the right answer
in your next try how about you think I'm
going to give you two more minutes two
more minutes to calculate your variation
if you guys don't solve it right I'm
going to give this opportunity to Arjun
Arjun is ready he's ready since the
beginning of the class I would so I
would check my solution you still have
one minute
all right King to d4 that's an
interesting idea why do you go to d4
how do we call this technique we call it
shouldering we're basically shouldering
our opponents king right so we're not
letting him get close to our upon now if
he goes King before what do you do
pawn f4 and right now we have the
opposition yeah he has to stick around
on on the B file he cannot get closer to
our key to our upon so he has to go King
b3 King g5 King c4 King f6 and now he's
not reaching this square this important
square he cannot create contact with our
pawn he's not in time so now he's going
to go King before King defy for King v3
wherever he wants we're going to take
the pawn and then just promote the point
so very counterintuitive
now what if he goes king c6
hmm
we're shouldering the king yeah we'll
keep on shouldering the king now if he
goes king c5 once again we move pawn f4
we create the opposition right this is
the only way to win if you go king of
six in this position that would be a
terrible mistake because I go King
before and then king e4 and I'm right in
time yeah but we win a temple by
creating the opposition and shouldering
so we're kind of combining two
techniques in this endgame one of them
is shouldering the other one is one of
the most important rules of the pawn and
gains opposition yeah okay one more one
more difficult one really difficult one
or do you guys want to play let us do
another difficult one difficulties oho
this is a tough one this is a tough one
I know you know it Arjun it's I know you
know it it's a very it's a very famous
one it's going to be white to move I
know you knew it I told you that most of
the most of the solutions that I'm going
to give you are going to be white if it
would be black to move it to be very
easy I would just push my pawn and then
it's going to be very difficult for you
to catch it
yeah I mean it still looks extremely
difficult for you to catch it you're
nowhere near close to entering or
entering the square
tell mater win I mean the better
question would be is it a draw or a win
I don't know
win win for who how can you win with
white is there any any way possible in
this universe to win with white if yeah
there's very few there's very few
options I think about it that will give
you a few more minutes
calculate calculate guys
I go there he goes there I go there he
goes there try to visualize it so what
are the candidate moves
that's one candidate see seven of course
no no it's white to move
so it's either c7 or some other moves
King h7 don't forget say say the piece
name as well yeah sometimes sometimes
there's more pieces that can go to the
same square correct you can only say the
square name if it's a pawn so you can go
c7 you don't have to say pawn to c7 but
when any other piece moves you have to
say the piece as well
so you're saying c7 and King to h7 all
right let's try both of them let's start
with c7 I'll go here and force to go
there yeah so now you do what you move
the King anywhere you want then I take
your pawn then you move the King
anywhere you want and what do you want
you want go here it doesn't matter
you're still not catching my pawn what's
the square are you touching the square
you're not touching the square so you're
not going to be able to catch it yeah
sure if it would be white to move twice
in a row then he would take the pawn and
that would be the chess becomes easy but
that's not how chess works I move once
you move once so I'm going to get a
queen and that's not good
yes
so c7 we eliminated yeah we calculate it
we realize is not the right solution and
then we move on to the next one let's
try King h7 going to do the same thing
I'm going to catch your pawn first then
you go here and then I go here and then
you go here and then I go here and once
again you don't catch my pawn right so
it seems really difficult to catch my
pawn but maybe somehow if you're tricky
enough you will be able to catch it
maybe you have to be extremely precise
you have to start fighting towards
achieving two goals catching two rabbits
in this particular instance yes yeah
King King g7 thank you all right so now
I have a few options let's start with
this one what do you do now King to f6
very good move now you're threatening to
do what if I take your pawn then you do
what you go to g5 you catch the pond and
this is a draw yeah but I'm going to go
forward what do you do now you have to
once again create two threats catching
the pawn and the second one is
supporting your own pond
exactly now you're threatening to play
King to d6 you're also threatening to
play King to f4 to catch the pawn right
so if I keep on going you do what now
you go to d6 and surprise we're going to
promote at the same time and that's just
going to be a draw right so you see
you're fighting towards achieving two
goals with your king but the only way to
do that is to approach it diagonally
yeah so yeah King g7 is the right move
what if I go h4
in the back King to f6 exactly what if I
King b6 we already saw yeah we go King
g5 and we cash the pond what if I go
here pond c7 King be seven I think you
lost right so no somebody else yes
you have options and you pick the only
one that's losing because right now if
you play king e5 I'm going to go h2 and
when you go c7 I go King b7 yeah and
then you go King d6 and then you're too
late like you go King D 7 and then I
check you I grab your pawn and that's
just a simple win yeah no not checkmate
yet but it's going to be very soon so
you have to be a little bit careful you
have to to control both this course
these 7 and d6 so what you have to do is
actually go King e6 or King to e7 both
of them make a drop and now if you go
King b7 I have the extra move King to d7
yeah my King doesn't have to go d6 to d6
where it doesn't support the promotion
but he can go to this 7 he can reach the
7 and this is just a draw I'm going to
promote you're going to promote and
that's going to be all she wrote
drop so that's it you see despite the
fact that they're very simple they have
very few pieces these spawning games are
extremely complicated yeah and sometimes
you have to combine a few ideas a few
theoretical ideas such as shouldering
such as opposition such as dudes one so
many young and the only way to master
this is through practice so keep
practicing keep practicing and you're
going to notice this type of endgame is
by heart
[Music]